hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to salute very Oh
or at least I assume it's pronounced
slow very oh and not slither aiyo
because if it's anything like agario and
it is in that you are a snake trying to
gobble balls to grow longer not that
that's funny it's not supposed to be
funny in any way it's a very serious
game where you're literally a snake and
I think it's actually derived from the
game snake where you're trying to get
little bits in your body and then you
grow longer but in this one there are
other snakes that want to eat you dead
and they are very good at that because
for some reason when you grow longer you
get a speed boost but I don't get a
speed boost when I'm tiny and short and
not really all that important oh god see
that guy everyone's just charging off
into the distance and I'm left alone you
give me you how do I get you oh that
ain't good
I don't even know I've only played it a
little bit to be honest I haven't gotten
good at the game not that I'm good at
agario but my candid observation about
this game is that I'm hesitant to call
it slow very oh when it seems to very
much be about oh but I got him he just
charged into my tail like I kind of want
to call this game totally okay I got it
okay I got it I got woah someone died
here okay well this is this is a
windfall for me this is beneficial to
favor game
let's go snake up some balls and we'll
get to business alright anyway so on a
more serious note this game actually is
much like agario it's fun just because
it's a quick multiplayer game to get
into and then you're competing with
other people who are trying dill dill no
I keep wanting to do that god damn it I
can't I instinctual II just want to go
after people when in reality the game is
different
I gotta make them I gotta like
circumvent him
do it I'm not worth it I'm tiny I'm
small I'm insignificant wow this guy's
big that guy's so big weird for me to
say oh you have to spend balls to go
fast huh got that guy's circling the
drain here wow it seems Oh God God so
bad also I'm trying to curse less not
that I think cursing is bad I mean [ __ ]
[ __ ] and what all but I was reading an
article on how to be funny because of
not funny it was an article talking
about comedy and it was saying that
vulgarity is an easy substitute for
comedy and wit when in reality it just
it just means that you're not trying
very hard to be witty oh I got him it
just means you're not trying very hard
to be witty so I'm trying to curse less
and come up with actual intelligent
words to say a little more everyone
knows how that's gonna turn out for me
the answer is not well the answer is
very unwise oh
out of my dick was it I mean I just
leave it to wazoo because I don't want
to put any cursing into it oh god these
nuts are after me why can't I play a
nice game a dick ball without Deez Nuts
chasing me down stupid dummy
haha scrublord look at how bad you are
you just slammed into the side of my
long snake there's no way to say that
but that sounds good and there's no way
to be a oh there's no way to oh this
this seems like a trap it seems like a
[ __ ] ass oh I almost got him though
that would have been something I just
need to protect my long snake I need I
didn't need to slither around a little
better so that my snake saves stays safe
shut up this is getting bizarre Hitler
Oh God what the [ __ ] it
oh man mr. ler I goddamnit okay the
snake seems smoother not so many hard
edges on my short and shriveled snake
right now but I mean eventually it's
gonna be big and proud and I'm gonna
have a channel through all this place
and just not that's not a penis I'm
trying to be less vulgar here guys I'm
trying to substitute vulgarity with wit
and it doesn't seem to be working very
well oh god damn it
is this Hitler again this frickin little
hit of ler this is mr. Liu Liu this
poopy face this turd looking pants
having the funny note akkad house it's
hard to come up with insults when you're
not allowed to curse you stinky breath
weirdo who is not ripped at me you're
not as ripped as my long snake as well
god I'm just going deeper into the
quagmire of death that lies at the heart
of this map to meet my meet my fate at
the hands of snakes that are longer and
stronger than me but deep I dive into
the belly of the beast as I conquer the
world
oh god this is gonna be bad I just see
trails of Sprint's no you can't do that
what are you even thinking of doing what
are you even trying to do there don't
even try it
gee you wait oh well that ain't good huh
darka Joshua Chris gosh just now snow no
way to fail there loser ass well just
stupid head what it's a sick Latino why
is there a thick Latino that doesn't
seem good at all I'll just I'll just
take up your sprint goo thank you there
is some strategy to this I I will admit
it actually is interesting strategy
because you're able to cross your own
boundaries but not other people's
boundaries so it leads like you can
eight people in less labels they fully
encircle you and just like lead you into
a death and destruction spiral that's
gonna end horribly for all parties
involved what are you doing I'm not even
gonna try oh where am I gonna kill from
here oh no this ain't good
Oh same good I'm trapped in the belly of
the beast everyone else I imagine that
everyone else when they're at their
desks playing this game or just
screaming at the top of their lungs
non-stop just like me I mean in reality
they're probably very common like oh no
I didn't I didn't make it ah [ __ ] but
I'm just like and that often leads to
panic moments and then horrible regrets
but everything's fine what's going on
here whoa oh my god that guy died what
the Frick oh [ __ ] ah [ __ ] he was big and
he died yeah I don't know if that was
worth wasting all the Sprint juice to
get over there it's not exactly my
territories that guy benefited from it
more than I did
I'm gonna kill ya I'm not going in for
any kill don't die don't die from the
little guy just that tiny guy gets me
just a tiny itty bitty one tiny bitty
one filled with good feelings in my
brain oh oh [ __ ] well don't look at me
like that
Ouija Ouija Wiegel yeah come here you
I don't know what that did but it was
good for me I'm 28 I'm ranked 28th anon
leaderboards but I'm doing meter me
mediocrity de Lili meet me do Curtis Lee
medium mido critically mm flow I don't
know Rowan I said I was gonna replace my
vulgarity with wit it's just I emptied
the vulgarity and then I emptied the wit
cuz I never had any to begin with so I'm
just stuck with my stupid brain in my
head
so long oh he said circling me no no I
didn't think so
you did good tap me it ain't gonna
happen cuz I'm too smart for he's still
coming after me
why he coming after me as if I'm worth
it maybe it's mabeline okay don't do it
why am i worth it
why you fight me what you fighting me
bro okay everything's fine everything's
fine
everything's not horrible but it's fine
I somehow dropped rank again cuz I spent
someone I shat out so many balls out the
end of my ass just [ __ ] the lack of
vulgarity i shat so many balls out the
enema oh hello so many balls out the end
of my ass that obviously I couldn't
reciprocate anything oh hello hi friend
how you I'm number 18 now this do you
good that guy almost just scooped up the
remnants of everyone else's mistakes
that's my motto in life follow other
people until they fail and then
capitalize on all the mistakes that
they've ever regretted in their life and
then make fun of them when they're dead
that's the mark of our wait oh boy thank
you thank you help e help Orton this is
awfully helpful mr. Hill per 1000 or so
much good juices also juicy oh so juicy
goodness Oh
so to see people are just ramming into
my body I can't I can't help the fact
that they're too stupid to avoid
everything that's in front of them
seems dangerous lady board baby I'm
number seven oh it's my first time
playing well my like my second time
playing but I didn't do I didn't do any
sort of good the first time I played so
this is the first time on camera and I
can officially say berbay all right oh
man if anyone takes this away from me if
arrow tries to rob me of my success I
beat the dock god damn it number 10 if
anyone tries to take away by success
Robby oh god damn it I'm off the
leaderboard well I can't say that it was
any one person it was probably concerted
effort from a whole bunch of people but
don't run into me I want to be I'm on a
peacekeeping mission I'm an ambassador
of fun times and happiness hey it's
another Marquis mu I haven't been able
to capitalize on anyone else's mistakes
just yet Wow it might happen soon
or else I'm gonna make a horrible
mistake oh no it's your mom don't even
think about it you losers
oh hello thank you please oh yes kindly
yes kindly would you can all just kindly
oh yes oh yes they would say a marquee
move on number five slay slay slay a
little less dangerously it's dangerously
I'm number four oh god I want to hold on
to my crown I want to hold desperately
on to my crown it's a new game so people
aren't exactly like the best at it which
is the only explanation that I can
produce for me XD do be sort of good in
this game
can't breathe what are you doing are you
doing with that okay okay alright so
that's live Aereo slither that's that's
a good old-fashioned game a dick ball
and if anyone doesn't like that one god
damn it you're not an American
I don't know so anyway you can play
solitaire out slowly free links in the
description thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you
thought of this game in the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video